hi I'm a native and I'm an IT operator
on my daily shift I carefully monitor
the event console displaying all events
that pop in for example an event
indicating that the web server is down
now I take the following steps based on
the event ID I check in our wiki's
manuals or our searching the web to find
out which steps I have to take to solve
the problem I log into the remote system
using my credentials for this specific
system I manually execute the required
commands on the command console I log
out a manually removed the event from my
to-do list the problem is that all of
these steps require a lot of time and
they are failure-prone I can type in the
wrong credentials or I can use the wrong
c'mon besides that I need to be highly
skilled to be able to work with a lot of
different machines and a huge
infrastructure isn't there anything out
there that makes my work more efficient
effective and reliable IBM redbooks
seems to have a solution for my problem
so let's check it out what changes
running my daily working tasks if I use
IBM one book automation in my event
console I can directly see that a ran
book is available for an event I can
launch the run book using the event menu
and then I can run the automation
and what happens now let's look at a
very simple example start and restart a
web server the run book guides me
through the steps that I have to take to
solve the problem of the event so here
are my steps check status of the web
server start the web server in case the
start of the check failed check again
the status of the web server if
everything is up and running in this
example my steps are automated actions
I run book can also be a combination of
manual and automated steps I can click
run to start the first automated steps I
get immediate feedback within the run
book I get guided through all steps that
I have to take in the action are
automated I do not need to remember the
host name the user credentials all the
commands because every operator can
write his tasks in a run book everybody
can exploit the experience of other
operators in a consistent way so what do
you think does this sound like your
working day is more effective efficient
and reliable using one book solving
problems requires less time because I
can alternate complex and repetitive
tasks
many thanks for listening